welcome to the hugging face task series
in this video we'll take a look at text
classification
in text classification models receive a
text as input and return class labels
and their associated probabilities
there are many variants of this task
that lets you analyze sentiment assess
grammatical correctness determine if one
question is a paraphrase of another or
determine if a statement is correct
according to a given text
we will not cover all of them in this
video you can take a look at the text
classification task page for more
details
sentiment analysis is the task of
determining sentiment of a given text
these models receive a text and return
either polarity or emotion in it
another variant is natural language
inference
and line models take a premise and a
hypothesis and return a label
if the hypothesis is true and the line
model returns entailment
if the hypothesis is false it returns
contradiction or if there is no relation
it returns neutral
question and a line models take a text
and the question and return entailment
if the answer to the question can be
found in a text and not entailment
otherwise
this model can be used in modeling
information retrieval problems
glue is a benchmark that is used to
measure the performance of nlp models
across 10 different tanks classification
tasks
these data sets are useful for
fine-tuning the text classification
models as well
text classification models are evaluated
on accuracy and the fund score the
metrics are calculated for each of the
class labels predicted for texts and
take the average to measure the overall
performance of the model
as an example use case you can classify
your customers reviews from the product
reviews or tweets using sentiment
analysis models to make better business
decisions
for more information about text
classification check out the task pages